our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what's unites us as Americans
is far greater than what divides us the
restaurant industry could lose seven
million jobs in the next few months
mark Strassmann went to a restaurant
helping laid-off workers find their next
meal all right thank you very much maybe
all foods of comfort you want to come
back for another meal just shoes wow
that's amazing but free lasagna and
vegetable soup hard to beat when you're
out of work and scared olivia del Turco
is a laid-off waitress it's such a help
during this was Ryan Smith's idea he's
the chef and owner of Atlanta's staple
house restaurant
Bon Appetit magazine named it America's
best new restaurant in 2016
a high dollar food tasters paradise
until the hell of kovat 19 closed its
doors on March 15th now more than ever
is the time to give we need to give
Smith started giving free lunches to
Atlanta's food service workers
unemployed waiters and line cooks
Busboys and baristas 50 servings of
comfort food a day and growing and just
thinking about all these people that
just lost their jobs and and no one can
control any of it
you've gone from cooking a luxury to
cooking a necessity yeah yeah definitely
community donations fund the feeding
nearly 20 recently closed Atlanta
restaurants have donated leftover
ingredients is a heavy one
Doug Heinz shuttered his restaurant
who's gonna take a crate onions but this
is the perfect venue across America
restaurants have found new ways to serve
in Denver SAFTA also feeds jobless
restaurant staffers
in New York the corona epicenter that
chains sauce feeds healthcare heroes on
the front line so far they've donated
thousands of pizzas to 35 hospitals
survival is a shared struggle the most
terrifying thing I've ever witnessed all
these restaurants are closing they're
dropping like flies it's kind of rough
out there you know servers now need to
be served if they think you like laid
off bartender brittany alexander she
picked up meals for four people me my
husband my son and then we have a
neighbor just to make sure we asked her
how much this food helps so much
understand think of it as nourishment
for the Soul the social distancing
version of a hug for CBS this morning
mark Strassmann atlanta so many people
helping out it's so great to see Gail I
know we could all use a nourishing hug
and a real one too